Our solutions for x are 5 plus or minus 2 times root 3. Great thinking if you
got this. Now, I know we haven't done that much practice yet. So that's totally
okay if you struggled. I'm sure you'll get the next one. We begin to solve this
problem by taking the square root of both sides. Since we have a quantity
squared, with a variable inside it, on the left. Taking this square root undoes
the square power. Leaving us with x minus 5 on the left hand side of our
equation. On the right hand side, we'll just have plus or minus the square root
of 12. Next, we'll add 5 to both sides to isolate our x variable. So, we'll
have x is equal to 5 plus or minus the square root of 12. And again, here this
5 is not like terms with the radical 12. So we can't add them together, we just
list them as a sum and difference. We need to simplify the root of 12, so we
break it into 4 times 3, this gives us our final answer of 5 plus or minus 2
root 3.